Cardiac Arrest very simply it's the
heart and it stops heart just stops many
different reasons but the leading cause
is a heart attack and a heart attack is
when the coronary arteries or the
vessels that supply the heart get
blocked there's a plaque um so that's a
heart attack if you're undergoing that a
person can walk around and say I think
I'm having a heart attack correct
whereas if they actually had a cardiac
arrest they're on the floor Cardiac
Arrest is usually a sudden thing right
so it you're you you're dropping you're
unconscious that doesn't mean you die
but it can mean that's what that means
heart stops heart attack to your point
Neil you're right people almost always
have symptoms indicating because it's a
slower process it could be fast but it
could also be slower so that means that
part of the heart muscle is no longer
getting nutrients specifically oxygen so
it starts to die